this is wicket a red panda  at 10 years old wicket is a fully grown  male with a height of just over two feet  or slightly larger than your average  house cat  as cute as he is his population has  decreased dramatically with less than 10  000 left in the wild  red panda in name it is not closely  related to the giant panda but actually  closer to the raccoon family  he loves to eat bamboo but won't turn  down the occasional bird insect or  mammal for a snack  native to the eastern himalayas and  southwestern china red pandas live in  trees and are nimble agile climbers  their reddish brown fur and bushy tails  camouflage them in their habitat from  predators like snow leopards  besides other animals humans pose a  major threat poaching and hunting them  for their fur  the forest that they live in are  shrinking fast and estimates say that  their population has been cut in half in  the last 20 years  this is the red panda  you